[Music]
this is star talked sports edition Neil
deGrasse Tyson here you're a personal
astrophysicist and today
we have as our guest Dale Earnhardt Jr I
got
Chuck Nice Chuck how you doing man hey
what's happening Neil all right all
right Gary Gary O'Reilly good to see you
again the one who gives authenticity to
this show as a former Soccer Pro in the
UK we have clips from my interview with
Dale Earnhardt Jr but Gary you you that
wasn't enough for you no and I wasn't
enough for you no a little bit of
physics I put into conversation was not
enough for you no no so I needed
something extra
okay just not anything but something
special and extra and so we we went out
and found a friend of ours that we had
back on the show many years ago Dr
Deandra Leslie pelecki undergraduate
degrees in physics and philosophy PhD in
condensed metaphysics Neil yeah
[Music]
this this is definitely uh for you
researcher in magnetic magnetic
nanoparticles focusing on medical
diagnosis and treatment a science
Communicator radio TV broadcaster
an author of the physics of NASCAR not
only
is Dr Deandra an expert in NASCAR but
she is also working with MBC on their
Motorsports and has become co-opted into
the Formula One family so I think we
have just the right person let's meet
our dear friend Dr Deandra Leslie
pelecki Deandra welcome to StarTalk
thank you for having me and blood to be
back oh you're back because when you
were last on I wasn't on that program so
it's my first encounter with you yeah
and uh and I guess if if you write a
book called the physics of NASCAR that
makes you pretty findable in our circles
so that it certainly does yes
all right so I didn't know about the uh
the
um magnetic particle research for the
purposes of medical Diagnostics yeah I'm
just going to find out how she makes
this transition uh how do you go from
there in medicine into NASCAR what's up
with that well nanomaterials were
actually one of the fields that uh the
public didn't understand and when they
first hit in I don't know the 90s and
the 2000s those of us working in the
field had to work very hard to explain
to people what we were actually doing
and the implications of what we were
doing so I learned a little bit more
about how to communicate with the public
then but actually the reason I got into
the race cars was because I was teaching
you know the intro 101 basic physics and
all of a sudden I realized I can teach
all of the Season cars and the kids
would be a whole lot more interested
than they would be if I'm doing balls
rolling down inclined planes the
frictionless incline planes and massless
pulleys are right right
so and and that was in the Genesis of
your book
it's actually interesting because
um I always like to ask if there are
physicists at the race shops and one of
the guys said no I don't think we have
any physicists you guys think everything
interesting is negligible
well science put down all right all
right well let's get into our first clip
with Dale
um is he abbreviated de junior is this a
like in the know like if your buddies
with him uh you know I want to be
respectful oh we just told him Junior
okay no other Junior
well there is another Junior but he's in
his 80s or 90s so yeah if you say junior
I don't know what you're talking about
okay all right so I wanted to know uh we
have several Clips we'll bring in here
but let's start off I wanted to know
what was different about each car if
each car had to had to submit to
regulations in size and and parameters
Ben what's the difference okay and then
Dale set me straight let's check out
this first clip NASCAR itself in stock
car racing for as for taking one example
of Motorsports that I'm familiar with
there's this long history of how the
cars have changed and developed but to
your point
um all of the cars are measured and and
there's a technical inspection and they
all have to meet the same measurements
requirements and so how does a
manufactured differentiate itself from
the others if they all have to appear
you know measure the same
body panels right and how about a piston
I mean yeah the Pistons have to be this
all all of the engines are
uh there's there's a bunch of
restrictions on how the manufacturers
can build their Motors and what's
allowed to be able to create amount a
certain amount of they want to Target on
torque and Peak torque and Peak
horsepower they don't want you to exceed
or get outside of this box they want all
of the manufacturers to live
in the same sort of area so that no one
has an advantage over the other
and what seems you know it seems about
that that would be conflicting to the
true core of racing racing is building a
fast car and building one better or
faster than New Mexico but like I say I
mean 50 to 75 years of History has you
know created this massive sort of
you know rule book with all kinds of
restrictions and limitations and
guidelines that everyone now has to fit
into this tiny tiny little space Deandra
I'm so I'm confused I mean I hear him
but what how do you advance a sport
if every time everybody's got it however
clever your engineers are they gotta
make it
they have to obey the rules and
regulations set out about the design and
then the in the aerodynamics the tires
the the restrictions focus on one part
of the car and not another and and
whatever part they don't focus on do you
have the freedom to make that part
badass and then win every race like I'm
just success these rules would ruin
horse racing
um so there's sort of two answers to
that one is that the reason for all the
standardization is because what NASDAQ
doesn't want to happen is that the
people who have the most money win
because then you just keep ramping
everything up all of a sudden this
American can afford the Andrew this is a
this is America that's right we like we
like our races just like our elections
Whoever has the most money should win
dies with the most toys wins yeah and
and we did that for a long time and what
happened was uh people started dropping
out of the sport one driver Mark chirx
Jr won the championship one year and the
next year his owner shut down everything
because he just couldn't afford to keep
doing the racing and that's how you kill
a series and so a lot of the
standardization was basically to save
the series now where the innovation has
really come in is that NASCAR designed
the Power Racing now which is called the
next gen car a lot of the Innovation is
there and so the teams have a small area
in which to work they can change Springs
shocks suspension geometry you know for
example when you stop at a stop sign you
go forward right right well your entire
car does that because the car is
attached to the top of the car is
attached to the wheels by Springs and so
that's your suspension well that
transfers weight and you know that
frictional grip you have depends on the
weight pushing down on the tires of the
car so every time the part of your car
goes backward forward to the side you
are changing the grip on your four tires
that is an incredible amount of Freedom
that the teams have now Junior doesn't
know that because he's not the one who's
trying to figure out what Springs and
what shocks we use for a particular
track so he doesn't see a lot of that
um and it's really a matter of how do
you match the car setup the suspension
mostly to a driver's style because you
could put Junior in one of those cars
you could put another driver in the same
car and one would be able to go faster
than the other and that doesn't
necessarily mean one is better than the
other just that the car suits one
driving style better you're saying
you're saying a car can have bespoke
suspension for the driving style of the
driver so Deandra let me ask let me ask
you this has there ever been pushback
from the teams where NASCAR said this is
what's going to come in as a restriction
this season and the vote tournament I'm
going nah not happening has there ever
been that or do they all do as they're
told
a lot of the image just for the
standardization came from the drivers
and the owners okay because imagine if
you're a driver driving for a team that
doesn't have as much money do you want
to spend 36 weekends a year running you
know 21st or 30th just because you don't
have enough money to make car faster or
do you want to have an equal platform
and then you've got a better chance
showing off your skill because it's not
the car that's winning it's the driver
who's winning
mm-hmm okay so when when you say that
when the restrictions come in who who
eventually ends up working the harder
the engineers in the pit or the drivers
themselves because they've got to adapt
and survive out there on the track good
question it really depends on the change
so some of the changes
um really affect the drivers more than
the teams but they're making a lot of
changes uh NASCAR is especially this
year uh they're trying out mufflers for
the first time they ran Mufflers as a
pre-season race
they only muffled them down to somewhere
around 80 90 decibels
what's what is this
well the point is that they were racing
at the LA Coliseum and people live
around there
[Music]
and it makes a huge difference that 20
decibels to the people who live outside
the nimbis the nimbies
or protested outside the Coliseum with
placards but you couldn't hear what what
chance they were screaming
let's go to my next clip where this
notion that you're doing something to
win the race but in fact Innovation uh
you know where does anything innovate
are is are the cars we drive on the
street because some people are saying
let's have Innovations for the regular
driver or do they have other Origins so
let's go back to my exclusive
conversation with Dale Earnhardt Jr on
just that while everything is really
tight in the rules there is this sort of
little small area that the manufacturers
tend to create advantages in for example
right now the Chevrolets would be
um they would appear the Chevrolets have
a little bit of an advantage on a track
that's a mile and a half in late and
their nose and the other components on
the body that they do have some Liberty
in allowed them to develop an advantage
over the other two manufacturers and
that Ebbs and flows back and forth as
the manufacturers continue to develop
and and introduce new pieces
in a subsequent year where other
manufacturers copy that Innovation they
might look at it and learn how to do it
better
and that's sort of been that's sort of
been the way that this Sports evolved
for 75 years is you know I'll make a
better mousetrap than you you'll look at
my mousetrap and you'll figure out what
I might have not seen and how they'll
take my idea and improve on that and it
just continues to just layer on layer
upon a layer on upon layer of of
improvements to the same theories and
ideas so I heard that many many uh
features of the modern internal
combustion engine car
oh their origin to Innovations in NASCAR
and let me just mention a few you tell
me if I'm right or like fuel injection
was that was that first in NASCAR and
car racing more broadly well I think
motor Motorsports more broadly NASCAR
actually hung on to the carbureted
engine a little bit longer than most I
think though that fuel injection and
those you know those types of
improvements on our road automobile the
car me and you buy off the dealership
floor those
he knows improvements in those cars
certainly come from Motorsports seat
belts uh safety Innovation and
um you know durability in suspension
components uh all of those things
originate originate from what we learn
on the racetrack the wear and tear and
the durability and we you know we'll put
these components to the test and we find
their weak spots the the manufacturers
pay attention to that they take that
back to the car that me and you buy off
the showroom for so Deandra there are
test pilots I love it is that a fair way
to think of them
um in some in some ways it is but you
know NASCAR is much more of a reactive
series
um if you look at the origins of
Motorsports they came about when The
Cars first got invented and
manufacturers were trying to convince
people these are good things these are
better than your horse and buggy for
example
um master has always been more about
selling cars and so there hasn't been as
much Innovation however
um they're very good at popularizing
things
and so I think for example there is a
material called compacted graphic iron
which is in between cast iron and ductal
iron and you know that engine blocks are
made of cast iron usually the problem is
they tend to crack well this material
which was invented in the 60s because we
finally got Metallurgy down to the point
where we could actually make it is a lot
lighter you can make much thinner
features and so you know one of the
things as manufacturers turn to electric
vehicles is they need to reduce the
weight of the cars so some of the
materials some of the tricks that razors
have been using to decrease the car
weight are things that will directly
translate to production cars especially
as we move to electric vehicles
of our Innovations Dr with NASCAR
in the sense of you know all the stuff
we can see with the aerodynamics we've
talked about the engine blocks we you
know we're going to talk about tires in
the next segment and there's there's
things on the floor of the car that are
built specifically to to add to
downforce are we are we at the limit or
are we just beginning
I mean what what is limiting us is money
uh-huh
how about that so yeah I mean
wintertime
I could have said that dude on the show
that kind of that kind of translates
across everything everything yeah it
does it does but time in a wind tunnel
is you know I'd forget how much it is
now about a thousand dollars an hour
according to that you know that teams
used to spend 12 hours in a wind tunnel
take the car back strip it and start
over again yeah and again that kind of
cost just keeps going up and up and up
but really the um the need for
Innovation changes from area to area
right as as the needs of the consumer
changes so like you just said right now
we're looking at the electrification of
pretty much our entire economy so now uh
the urgency for lighter materials more
that are durable that can stand up to
you know the road that becomes very very
important as before it was a luxury like
to have carbon fiber in your car that oh
look how cool that is so cool well now
it's like yeah you you kind of need that
um yeah exactly and so a lot of the
processing figuring out how to make
carbon fiber in extremely intricate
shapes for example a lot of that comes
out of F1 and out of NASCAR
yeah yeah cool so is there is there an
area that the the engineers haven't
really got heavily into yet doctor in
terms of where you think you know what
if we go there we could really make
something special happen
um yes and it goes back to nanoparticles
um
lubricants
so one of the things you have to worry
about is a cooler engine produces more
horsepower
and everything why is that so
um because you get more air molecules in
when the air is because it's denser
right wow look at that I don't know that
that is so simple oh that is such a
simple concept mic drop right there
right of course so could you put it
could you put a little cooling thing in
there to shrink it back down or that
would just be extra weight and oh my God
that's the thing um if you were able to
make fluids that could transfer heat
better away from the car you would have
an advantage and the best part is
there'd be no way I mean F1 made a rule
against Nano materials how are they
going to find a honestly yeah
[Laughter]
magnifying glass yeah there you go oh
that's pretty funny
glass
however however you just made like well
then again we are moving away from
combustion engines but still uh I I
can't believe nobody's figured out a way
to make a lubricant that actually cools
the engine at the same time so like it
wouldn't just be motor oil it'd be motor
oil and some kind of additive bring the
temperature down yeah that would be
amazing
on the cars and the air vents that you
know not just for downforce but as a
natural
free coolant as you're traveling 200
mile an hour air is going to cool stuff
down that's true well yes and no so the
most important thing you have to keep
cool in a race car is the driver
and uh don't worry baby I'm cool
so they're you know we've really closed
up the cockpits and so the problem is
it's getting to be 120 130 140 degrees
Fahrenheit in the car okay and so we're
now worried about how do we keep the
driver's temperature from getting up too
high because when your temperature gets
up high you lose your ability to think
correctly and you know you don't want to
be doing bad at 200 miles an hour so the
other area of cooling is ways that you
can uh you know Force cooled fluid
through A Shard or you know something
more sophisticated than dumping a bag of
ice down your fire suit at the next pit
stop right right but of course NASA
there's spacesuits where there are there
are there are tubes that move through
that thread the suit to particular areas
where you can most benefit from a heat
exchange uh if you're trying to stay
warm or cold either right so yes so
that's interesting I wonder and so
drivers do have these shirts they're
called cool shirts very descriptive name
that are just campillary tubes sewn onto
a shirt but the biggest problem they
have right now is the capillary tubes
tend to clog
and then you're stuck in the car with
warm water going through the suit so
that's an area if you're going to start
a business that would be a really good
area to go into
yeah he's a great driver but we lose
every race because he insisted that we
put an air conditioner
once the drive with the windows open
right and a stereo and a stereo
[Laughter]
guys we gotta take a quick break but
when we come back more of my exclusive
interview with the one and only NASCAR
Legend Dale Earnhardt Jr supplemented by
the physics expertise of
Dr Deandra Leslie pelecki author of the
physics of NASCAR where else are we
going to get that
but from her we'll be right back
we're back segment two StarTalk sports
edition featuring my exclusive interview
with Dale Earnhardt Jr and we've got
with us
Dr Deandra Leslie pelecki who wrote the
book on the physics of NASCAR and guess
what that book is called I'm gonna go
with the physics in NASCAR the physics
of NASCAR all right something had me
intrigued I heard that they don't
inflate their tires with air
air like air the mixture of nitrogen and
oxygen instead they remove the oxygen
and stick just nitrogen in the tires and
I'm thinking why oh my God check this
out we want
um the the Heat
that's created in the tire I believe the
nitrogen will be less affected by that
temperature
and so this air is going to increase
right and you're gonna if as the tire
gets hot and gets warmer uh the the size
of this tire we want to minimize the
change in that tire from the moment it
leaves the race leave bit Road and goes
out on the racetrack and performs and so
they found a a mixture that would be
less volatile less affected by
temperature the tire
like the Inside Edge of a right front
tire during a run is going to go over
250 degrees 280 300 degrees whoa and so
the air inside of the tire is affected
by that heat and as the air increases in
the tire the size of the tire changes
that changes the setup and the way the
car drives and feels you want all of
those things to be minimized and so
um using nitrogen and and has gained the
teams a bit control a bit of control and
um predictability I think over just how
much the tire is going to change we you
know we have a Target pressure
uh working with uh working with Goodyear
they give us a lot of Tire data and
they'll tell us you're you know your
your target pressure for maximum grip
and performance in the tire is going to
be 55 degrees or 55 pounds and so if the
tire is likely to gain 15 pounds in you
know in the race in the race while we're
racing it if it's going to gain 15
pounds and sort of plateau then we want
to pull off Pit Road with 40 pounds of
air in the tire whoa yeah and so there's
which is uh it's there's not a lot of
there's not a there's
most of the teams all understand where
they need to be there's not somebody out
there that's smarter than the next guy
trying you know that knows a little bit
more and is doing that job a little
better Goodyear provides uh all of the
teams of tons of Tire data on sidewall
stiffness and all kind of pliability in
the Rubber and everything else to help
them understand
you know air pressures and what they
need to run and there's also a safety
Factor like if you start the air
pressure too low the tire itself will
come apart over time so DeAndre I have a
zillion questions after that clip there
so first of all are they nitrogen is
slightly lighter than oxygen is this why
they're removing the oxygen and using
primarily nitrogen no actually it's not
um what they want so we call it a tiger
build it's the difference between the
tire pressure when you're on Pit Road
and the tire pressure you know when
you're just running green flying laps
that build
um you want to be predictable now
imagine if you have just say a
compressed air
you know and you put it from a
compressor into the tire that air is
going to have a lot of water in it and
you heard him say the temperature is
going to get between 250 300. let's
above the boiling temperature water
right yep so what's going to happen is
all of a sudden you're going to get a
change in pressure and that change in
pressure will upset the car enough for a
drive or uh to crash
so what they found was that by using
nitrogen which is dry has no oxygen has
no water in it rather that made the
builds more predictable
wow wow
wow damn okay so so a couple of things
but under pressure the water would would
turn to steam and an even higher
temperature than 212. so maybe if it's
getting up to 250 260 maybe that's right
300 is
um not out of the question
so okay so now I asked him why don't
they preheat
the nitrogen before they put it in the
tire then you don't have to build
anything you come out of the pit ready
you know ready for prime time and he
didn't have a good answer for that do
you have any insight into that oh yeah
the answer is because NASCAR won't let
you nope
you know honestly that one I understand
because I do not want people with
compressed air cylinders which by the
way are sort of dangerous heating them
up right right you're just asking for an
accident yeah
what could go wrong yeah possibly go
wrong oh I did manatee no
no I didn't want any I did want to
mention on that a couple crew chiefs
every so often decide they're going to
get really smart and instead of using
nitrogen they decide they're going to
use argon or Xenon you can put your also
ideal gases
um and what they learn almost inevitably
is that the additional cost is not worth
any gain in performance
if you go to gases down on the noble
gases on the right hand side of the
periodic table they really need to use
Krypton
that's the one
they they haven't right yeah okay then
you get Superman power out of that one
I'm pretty sure or or or at least your
car won't have superpower anymore yeah
no oh Kryptonite oh yeah sorry my bad my
bad and obviously it'll have to be green
oh yes yeah yeah all right it comes
without saying
um what what if the tire pressure is too
low
because don't don't the tire don't you
get to go quicker with lower tire
pressure but this the trade-off is the
Integrity of the tire itself yeah
there's a hot there's a happy pressure
spot for a tire okay if there's too
little air in it you'll actually see the
sidewall start to flex yeah and if you
go to a track a small short track
Martinsville which is a half mile they
will actually start the cars out between
9 and 11 PSI
and they will build up to 35 32 psi
during the course of a run but if you
started at 32 you'd get a build and then
they'd be so big that you'd be having
less of a tire in contact with the track
which would give you less room
right right so I we did a whole uh
explainer video on the tire pressure and
if you multiply the weight of the car
sorry if you multiple if you multiply
the area of tires in contact with the
road
by the tire pressure you get the weight
of the car and so yeah if your tires get
over inflated they have to Rise Up On A
Center Line there so that all those all
those numbers still come out but believe
it or not that's the same for your
regular car that you're driving on the
every single person you know there's a
recommended PSI for the for uh and uh
for the for the tire themselves there's
a pressure it has to be and they tell
you if you run it low you wear your
tires out uh and if you run it on edges
yeah you know so yeah you it screws up
the tread right right but then again see
we always think of straight line speed
and grip for a tire
but when you watch Nascar and I I
watched a couple of races just so as I
can understand a little bit better
there's a lot of Need for lateral grip
so if you over inflate a tire it becomes
too higher pressure then that's where
your loss comes in surely ah well now
now you got I mean that's this is where
I want them to over inflate all the
tires now you just made this game more
exciting you're welcome
[Music]
do we have a sweet spot for lateral grip
because if I'm gonna overtake or come
underneath a
car in front of me I'm gonna need to
have that lateral ability without just
sliding all the way off yeah lateral
grip is actually much more important
than the speed down the street aways for
example
um so one of the problems is that if you
are under inflated when you turn you can
imagine you're actually shearing the
sidewalls of the tire yep yep and if
it's way too low you could actually
share them off this fire right so that
would be dangerous and then if it's too
high you just simply don't have the grip
to make the turn and you're gonna hit
the wall look at that well so when you
watch Nascar and you think it's just
about driving fast right and then by
sitting down with Dale Earnhardt and
have him sort of reflect on what's going
on inside the driver's head a good
driver's head and what is he thinking
about is he just do is it pedal to the
metal or is there some other sort of
thinking about the engineering and
physics I know one thing he's thinking
what damn it's hot no okay let's find
out let's find out what else the driver
is thinking from this next clip let's
see what's going on check it out in our
racing since we drive on ovals and we
are always turning left and we're always
going in the same direction
we really need the right side of our car
to perform almost like a wing on an
airplane and how do you if we have a car
that's tracking straight down the
straightaway
uh if we can control how much y'all the
y'all movement or how much the car goes
into y'all into the corner and almost
you know it almost is the car pivots
into y'all into the corner that right
side becomes a wing the air now is
pushing on that right side trying to
straighten the car out that means I can
go faster I can match the gas and go
harder and so we control the all
movement
and we
focus on side force or the amount of air
pushing on that right side of the car
trying to keep that car from spinning
out and losing control
and uh you know that that's been that's
really been
the main focus in NASCAR and oval track
racing probably over the last two
decades he's saying yaw right yaw not
y'all yeah I know I thought he was
talking about the people's watching
so yeah he's using he's using terms from
aerodynamic flight airplanes and
aerodynamics so so can you comment on
that Deandra
yeah so uh the aerodynamics uh the race
car are really important and what he's
talking about is you know you have a car
and it's coming straight towards you and
if the car is in zero yacht the tires
are both lined up straight
like this it's actually better if you're
turning left it's better for the car to
be a little bit like this so the right
side's poking out that means that you'd
get more air coming along the right side
of the car that's going to give you side
Force that's going to help you churn
and so you know everyone has pretty much
the same mechanical grip that is the
weight of the car so anything you can do
to increase your aerodynamic grip will
give you more speed
so could I design the right hand side of
the car in a slightly advantageous way
to build that out to kind of make it
naturally be doing yeah
or am I now in trouble with the big
people your Dynamic cheater he's a
cheater aerodynamics let's say that you
came up with something that actually
accomplished that was it in the rules
yeah you asked her would probably make
it illegal right after that race
oh after you want you have to win the
race first of course
I'm getting laughed out of town
why is this NASCAR shaped like a rhombus
what is going on
so also don't notice that yeah okay
I mean all right we've seen the drafting
we've seen ridiculously close drafting
we've seen them in the single file we've
seen them three of breasts but when
they're racing and in different stages
and different positions are there is
there a sweet spot or are there at times
multiple sweet spots which the drivers
themselves can exploit
to the location among other cars Gary
say it again a sweet spot as a sweet
spot you mean location among others yeah
where all of a sudden the aerodynamics
are more beneficial for the car trailer
so is that kind of I mean there's all
sorts of thoughts that go off in your
mind once you've started to watch one of
these things
yes the the question of how the air
coming off another car affects your car
is one that has been with Nascar ever
since drafting was discovered in the 60s
yeah um it's almost more of a question
of making sure you're not in certain
places yeah so when you get right behind
someone if you get to one side in fact
we saw this at Atlanta this week uh one
driver just actually moved behind the
other from right to left and the driver
in front spun out there was no contact
no I saw that change the air wow so much
yeah that it made him spin out oh man he
he did a draft pit move on him
okay so with the outer wall
how is that affecting apart from the
fact you don't want to be hitting it how
is that affecting the aerodynamics on
the cars that race closer to the wall as
opposed to those inside of the track
so if you're running the outer wall
you're at a slight disadvantage because
you're going a longer distance right
right right okay however if you're
running the outer wall some drivers uh
could take advantage of sort of the
cushion of air between the car and the
wall and pick up a little speed that way
now you have to have some guts to do
that because the closer you are to the
wall the less tolerance you have for
error wow all right so what's
interesting there if
because if the more you draft and the
more you become efficient
the maybe you could work it so that it's
one fewer pit stops to refuel that can
make a very big difference it
it can uh at
depend how many caution
load up
F you all how many laps you get
depends how many of those laps are green
and how many are yellow because
obviously you get they're a few
knowledge when you're not going as fast
wow okay yeah I
thought just do all the
fans know all these details that are
going on or they just want a fast race
and an occasional crash no they don't
some know some aren't interested I mean
that's the great thing
um I was out at Las Vegas two weeks ago
just going out and talking to fans about
some of this stuff and a lot of them
really want to understand why isn't my
driver winning what's happening why did
he crash here so that's the great thing
about using Motorsports to get people
interested in math and science they want
to know yeah I have one friend who's in
the NASCAR and he's you know
uh he's obsessed so like he's with all
this stuff that we're talking about and
there's something wrong with him though
because he actually I'm serious he has
an autographed Tire slick that he uses
as a a coffee table
like he's saying that so he's in that
space all right all right what are you
doing are you critiquing him because of
his interior
designing him because he likes Nazca
well first of all he thinks I'm gay
because I don't have a tire slick as a
coffee table so that should let you know
where he's going
um what different wavelengths we are
you got to take him we got to take him
but we're gonna come back with Deandra
lesliecki telling us about the physics
of NASCAR and in the final segment I
look forward to just learning about
transition to Electric uh any other
thoughts and physics insights that are
going on in that fascinating sport when
Star College sports edition continues
we're back start talk sports edition
featuring my exclusive interview with
Dale Earnhardt Jr otherwise known as
Junior
and we've got deep physics Insight
coming to this episode from Dr Deandra
Leslie polecki who wrote the book the
physics of NASCAR you know I asked him
about
going Electric
and if you go electric then there you
might have aerodynamic noise but you
don't get that engine noise that engine
noise that is so characteristic of the
sport and so I had to ask him about it
what happens if the music goes away and
it's just Silent Running check it out I
think their Ambitions are absolutely
there I don't know that there's concrete
plans of what that looks like but they
know that as you know there's an adage
or a or a phrase that we used to say all
the time uh in racing in NASCAR and that
was win on Sunday and sell on Monday and
what that meant is the car the
manufacturer that would typically win on
Sunday they would go they were going to
have a good day at the dealership on
Monday they were gonna oh yeah yeah if
Chevrolet was successful on the
racetrack their belief the reason why
they're in Motorsports in general is to
sell Automobiles and so if they're set
Dan that they're trying to sell to the
market is doing well on the racetrack
then more people are likely to buy that
car and so
um
that still
has some truth to it now the race car
that I'm right you know that we raced on
the racetrack isn't anything like you're
gonna buy off the showroom floor but
um you know we still
we still sort of adhere to that idea
that
um you know the manufacturers their po
their whole purpose is to raise you know
the profitability of their of their yeah
why not why not of course did it and so
yeah yeah and if they're and if they're
building hybrids and they're building
and studying how to build electric cars
fully electric cars then we too need to
adapt some of that technology we need to
make it we need to be we need to be a
place where the manufacturers want to be
to be able to Showcase that technology
because just like we talked about at the
start of this conversation if hybrids is
the future and if if fully uh you know
fully electric cars are the future for
the consumer
then where are they going to truly test
that technology where are they going to
put that technology to the ultimate test
that's on the racetrack that's our
belief and I believe it's the
manufacturer's belief as well plus I own
an electric car and as you surely know
they're very high acceleration right
yeah and it's just a massive door very
very high torque at low speeds I mean
every so that's an interesting feature
that could manifest in interesting ways
for races designed just for that kind of
car right I think that that's true in
another conversation is
what will be fascinating to me is as
hybrids become more commonplace in
Motorsports we lose that combustion
engine sound the bra you know the engine
breaking of deceller decail into the
corner the sound of the RPMs
accelerating out of the corner we as I
say we race car drivers listen to those
noises to determine whether we are at
above or beyond the level of grip right
or we're over accelerating over over
um we're over put or pushing I'm talking
to you the sounds are talking to you
yeah and so when that's gone when you
get into an electric car you lose some
of that you lose some of the
understanding of what that combustible
engine is telling you I think that's
going to be so fascinating watching
drivers that are that have sort of lived
Both Worlds right so 30024c Electric
NASCAR anytime soon
yes uh the current generation of car are
they designed with the intent of
eventually being able to add hybrid
features to it and what junior said is
exactly correct the manufacturers are in
NASCAR to sell cars right when they're
trying to sell electric cars NASCAR will
be racing electric cars I think the
important thing there is that NASCAR is
in a position to change people's minds
and so the people who now say I hate
electric cars may get used to it may
change their mind about electric cars
based simply on you know NASCAR adopting
them so Deidre I just had an idea all
right have you ever seen low riders that
move into town real slow yep if you want
to sell low riders you got to have a
slow NASCAR
that are bobbing up and down and they're
just slow and they're there to be looked
at as you drive by that's a new kind of
NASCAR Gary isn't Formula One having
that problem
yeah maybe it is but uh
I don't think anyone's buying a Formula
One car out of a showroom
hey I must ask you what you heard there
was Dale Earnhardt Jr was the
relationship
the the the intuitive relationship of
sight sound and vibration everything
if the NASCARs are now electric does
that relationship get broken between
driver and vehicle and how how are we
going to solve that problem if that is
now going to be a problem of the future
so they no longer become one with their
car
no
oh I don't think so um so there's two
ways that the drivers are Simpson things
in their car one is Eyes Ears right and
the other and that's where sound will
come in the other one however is through
their their butt basically is they're
feeling how the balance of the car is
Shifting as they're you know as you lose
fuel you lose rear grip for example as
your tires were you lose grip they feel
that in the seat and after just
accordingly how fast they go to make
sure they're not exceeding the limits of
grip so that will still be there with
the electric cars I've talked to drivers
who have driven both and they say it is
a very different
technique to make an electric cargo fast
that it is an ice car but when when they
rely on that engine rev as an audible
clue as to where they are in terms of
the power output in terms of when they
need to make their maneuver if that's
just
how do you tap into that as a driver
life's life's on the dashboard yeah
yeah they have a
um uh what do they call it was a hat
it's not a heads up dashboard yet but
it's an electronic a digital dashboard
yeah and so they can pull it up they can
see the RPMs they can see how close they
are to Pit Road speed they can see
diagnostics for the engine
this is like Luke this is like the thing
that Luke was was going to use uh the
thing that came down there is yes right
trust the force Luke trash pulls it away
right away and then you hear R2 going
what are you doing you idiot look at all
this technology how would you trust the
force wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
R2 doesn't speak well you know why Luke
understands Chuck was interpreting Neil
Luke understands I don't want you to
embarrass me on my show by not knowing
that R2 is not have
here's the thing I mean you gotta
suspend so much disbelief in
except anything
Star Wars and you're gonna draw the line
at the talking robot
now my problem with this is if I go to
reach the radio while I'm driving on an
empty road I have a concern I don't want
to be on a NASCAR track with 20 other
cars at 200 miles an hour going oh what
is that heads up this display say what
was that again and I don't need to be
looking there when I need to be looking
there
so surely that audible note allows me to
focus with my eyes and use this other
sense here
you know it definitely does it
definitely does it's something you don't
have to learn
there there are other things that become
intuitive as you drive and I only say
this not that I've ever driven NASCAR
but I I ride motorcycles and the same
thing happens there is no
instrumentation when you're riding 95
miles an hour or on a twisty Road you
don't ever look at instrumentation but
also at that speed a lot of your hearing
but you rely on to listen to the motor
is also uh impaired because of the rush
of wind yeah and so you find other ways
to feel the road to field the bike to
you know you're at a certain speed when
you go to turn and because it's a
gyroscope there's a certain amount of
force that you need to use in order to
pull the bike so I without ever looking
down or hearing the engine I know oh I'm
a buffet 50 miles an hour right now
going into this turn from how much force
I have to pull on the on the bars to
pull the bike down into a turning
position so these are all things that
you just when you are deprived of any
sense you find another way to sense the
circumstance that's that's all I'm
saying let's let's jump into another
clip of my exclusive interview with
Junior
and Andrew can I call him Junior and am
I allowed everyone calls him Junior have
a good thank you thank you I don't want
to be out of order here so
um my exclusive interview with Junior
where we talked about
safety
safety and he said safety is not a
destination
and so I wanted to know how safe is
NASCAR these days so check it out there
is a lot of subtle things
um you know the the wheel tethers like
you say there's there's tethers to the
hoods of the cars so they don't go
flying into the grandstands when they
come removed from the cars and crashes
but
um there's been a lot of things
there is this um safety is a is not a
destination and you know there's no
there's no in-game
we I Neil when I was driving cars in
1995 I thought those cars were as safe
as they could be and and it's miles from
where we are today and what we've
learned and what we've you know it's not
just the car isn't your head now
attached yeah to so because there's this
thing on this on this thing we call a
neck and your head is moving 200 miles
an hour right yeah people are thinking
they thought it's the car know your head
is moving 200 at the car stops your head
keeps going yeah and that's you know
that's uh that's a fatal injury that's
part of my own my father's uh injury
that caused him to lose his life uh the
basal skull fracture is is something we
heard a lot in in years past but when
the Hans device comes out which was
developed because of of the many drivers
like my father that had this injury
um the Hans device basically kind of
keeps your head from coming off of your
show voters in those high high speed
Rigs and so you know I also learned
we've learned a lot about the uh the
head surround which uh the padding
around the helmet itself to try to
protect protect drivers from concussions
which uh which I know a lot about myself
unfortunately DeAndre does it does it
take a tragedy to introduce a safety
feature
I mean it kind of seems like it does but
mustard I guess I'm asking
in some way somewhere it does because
there are all things that can have
proof that you you can't predict so for
example one of the things we thought at
one point was the stiffer a car was that
is the less give it had the safer it was
so you were you were closing the driver
in a cage that would not allow him or
her to you know get any of that energy
well it turns out you want a car stiff
but not too stiff and so we're still
learning about how stiff to make a car
for example
um so we went through the same thing
with safety belts uh the problem is if
you are studying Motorsport safety you
don't get a lot of data points every
year
so there are you know less than 30
serious accidents in NASCAR by serious I
mean you know someone hitting a wall
really hard uh someone going upside down
catching on fire we don't have a lot of
those so if you're trying to study how
to prevent them you just don't have the
data to be able to predict everything
that's going to happen oh so that's a
good problem then
it is the data on you don't have the
data on bad accidents because there
aren't bad accidents right I mean that's
kind of interesting well there are bad
accidents but there aren't enough of
them that you could you know it's like
if you have an incomplete data set and I
asked you to predict something from that
you're not gonna be able to predict
everything okay okay but if you take the
element of danger away
are you not then
affecting the certain bit of something
that attracts the crowds too he's
talking about me he's being polite he's
saying if you take the I'm looking at
you Chuck the potential of death out of
the sport don't you get rid of the
Macabre uh people like Chuck Nice who
just love to don't want to see anybody
get hurt but are thrilled by the
potential of it happening
Maybe
you may but you know there's another
group of people who who have no interest
in that look at look at sports car
racing they very rarely have accidents
and there's a whole slew of people who
follow that yeah yeah yeah yeah and
listen I I think that uh as long if
nobody gets hurt crashes are spectacular
but what you want to see at the end of
it is when the guy gets out
and they walk and they walk away like
yeah that is the happiest you can be
it's like you saw the spectacular crash
and then you saw a guy get up and walk
off and you know and it looked and it
looks back right look at the Badgers in
the middle of that yeah like you know
that you know but because it's really I
mean there's I mean we went through it
in the in the NFL this year we actually
saw an ambulance take a player off of
the field first time and God knows how
long that's happened and it was really
just kind of almost like a you you felt
it was like a national tragedy because
it's something about that shared
experience of seeing it all together it
was awful it was just awful so you just
never want to see it so for me Neil the
chilling words by Dale Earnhardt Jr
there at the end concussion that's
something I know a lot about
unfortunately
um from your discussion and we've not
got into hearing him say this but he's
going to donate his brain to science
once he passes away because of the
concussions he has yeah I know a little
fine Devil's in the detail there so it's
that sort of thing where you're saying
people need to know that much more and
so to your point doctor the data points
are gonna come from a whole load of
different sources not just from the Cars
themselves
most definitely and in fact one of the
things Junior has done already
including in addition to donating his
free is just speaking out and getting
out of the car when he had a concussion
and telling people look I it's not safe
to drive when you have a concussion
because there is that you know Macho you
know I'm going to have a broken jaw and
drive I'm gonna have a broken arm and
I'm still gonna get in the car he really
changed a lot of people's attitudes
about that and so he's done a great
service to the sport that way so Gary I
think we have an extra clip on we do we
do so research let's see what's going on
there check it out I feel like that um
there's been a bunch of studies on NFL
football players and other athletes as
well it wasn't anybody really in the
Motorsports industry that was looking at
this and and thinking and considering
donating their brain oh so that came
after the football awareness yeah I saw
all of that happening and saw the the
you know the ground as well support to
try to provide anything for research
right to move to move this further I met
with a lot of doctors in my own
Rehabilitation that I fell in love with
and really respected and I wanted to
help them and do the right thing as well
for them well beyond my life I wanted to
continue to be an advocate for helping
other people and so you know anything
they can learn from my experiences and
and anything they can learn from
anything that I can do post post my life
I will you know after I'm going I would
I would want to be able to do that I I
um so yeah that was a very easy decision
for me yeah I'm glad we we had that clip
so that really that completes the the
picture of this treasure this American
treasure Dale Earnhardt Jr and what he's
done for the sport and what he'll
continue to do for the sport even in
death uh DeAndre do you have any sort of
uh closing remarks you can give us based
on all you've heard and what you know
and your wisdom and insight
really enjoy listening to drivers talk
physics because when they talk they ends
of the racing to people like us they
feel compelled to use you know the right
words and talk about aerodynamics and
that but what's really fascinating is
that they have an experience of physics
that you and I don't have because they
have all the g-forces all the Turning
you know all the all the feelings that
you get driving a car and I think it's a
really great way to sort of merge these
two worlds and I'm really glad you
talked to Junior because I think he's
one of the great ambassadors of the
sport
so we learned as well not it's been a
delight Deandra to have you back on Star
Talk where do we find you what's your
social media footprint uh I am at Dr
Deandra on Twitter I am at Dr Danver two
on Instagram and I think I can find my
my page my website building speed it's
building speed.org that's where I put
most of my really technical stuff about
Motorsports but then again I also write
two columns a week for NASCAR talk for
the NBC
um Sports and you'll find things on
there that cover everything from uh
things that we talked about today with
the tire to the odds of you know someone
winning the Daytona 500. wow okay so
that's the math and the physics coming
coming through there it's been a delight
thank you for giving your time to us and
our uh Sports loving audience always
thank you for having me all right Gary
good to have you man pleasure my friend
all right Chuck this has been another
episode of Star talk sports edition the
Dale Earnhardt Jr interview from Neil
deGrasse Tyson here as always bidding
you to keep looking up
[Music]